hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we were back on Apex legends again
and the e a press conference for apex
listens just finished up and we got some
awesome news to talk about they went
around for about 30 minutes we got some
stuff to talk about a new weapon a new
event coming back in season 2 and as
well a new character Watson which we're
gonna be talking about a little bit what
her abilities do and her backstory but
just only a little bit of that as well
as but as always like the V if you do
enjoy subscribe before new I cover the
informational side of apex legends that
being the balance changes the hero
updates the patch notes leaks everything
like that so if you want to be kept up
today with everything happening within
the world of apex legends and never miss
out on an update deftly stay subscribe
to the channel on top of that I also
cover the lore of the characters in apex
legends and my goodness is this
characters lore gonna be [ __ ] insane
but as always Twitter and discord in the
description down below and let's get
started with today's video
so first up season 2 is gonna be called
battle charge and it's gonna be coming
in July 2nd so we have a little bit of
about roughly less than a month to go
but it's still gonna be a little bit of
time there will be a slight off season
but yes July 2nd is gonna be apex
legends season 2 also known as battle
charge it will be coming with new map
changes new map event changes in terms
of things happening throughout the map
and just not just new areas new
mechanics and a new legend one of these
new things is a weapon and is a past
weapon from titanfall 2 so if anybody is
a titanfall fan you will understand it
the L star is coming back into apex
legends the developer said that it was
going to be a gold weapon so we'll have
a very rare rarity and it will also be a
care package weapon like the Mastiff or
the crater so definitely get ready for
that and go enjoy those care packages
try to get the L star because according
to the developers
it is very overpowered weapon which is
why it's a gold weapon on top of that it
can also shatter doors which is one of
the few things in the game that can
shatter door so that's really
interesting might not be super useful
but you can shredder by shooting at them
and there's also going to be two new hop
ups coming to the game I don't know one
knows what they are the developers were
just saying just to be on the lookout
for that and there was a tease that the
Mozambique will actually be viable who
knows it might have to do with the new
hop-up coming maybe who we a do a will
that Mozambique I'd love to see that but
yeah it's always good to see this really
shitty weapon actually be viable but I'd
love to see how that plays out going
over a bit of stuff that we already know
is that the battle
is not going to include challenges for
daily and weekly and they will help you
rank up these will be crafting materials
to make their also be enough crafting
materials to make yourself a legendary
item throughout the past and it will be
a lot easier to make it to level 100 in
this battle pass and as we all know
there's going to be new legendary skins
and every 25 levels coming and here is a
bit of the images for the legendary
caustic skin and one of the are 301
skins coming into the battle past for
season 2 and I think that last skins
shown up on screen while they were
talking on the front here I believe that
looks like a Spitfire but I could be
wrong
that was just my interpretation of that
skin on top of that for all you've good
players and all you pro players and
stuff like that season 2 will come with
a ranked mode it's gonna have six tiers
you're gonna be going from bronze all
the way to apex predator depending on
your rank and depending on the rank that
you get at the end of the season you
will be getting better exclusive rewards
they didn't really say what ranked mode
is going to be coming with and other
tidbits and stuff like that but it was
just they're just flat out saying it's a
ranked mode they'll most likely update
us later as we come closer to July 2nd
and now here is the video that everyone
has been waiting for this part is the
10th legend apex Legends character
Watson coming in season 2 here's some
gameplay of Watson her tactical ability
is this electrical fence pole that the
leaks have been confirmed true she can
place up to 12 poles what you have to
make sure that your energy doesn't
overheat so you can either place two
poles very very far or 12 poles very
close which enables lots of gameplay and
allows you to shut down multiple choke
points at once as long as you can serve
that energy which is gonna be excellent
to see her alt is this electricity thing
going on on-screen it basically
decreases the time that your tactical
ability is going to charge it so when
you're within the zone that of that
little ultimate you're going to be
charging your tactical faster but if
you're outside it's going to be going
slower teammates within that and you of
course will also be getting shield when
within that range it also stops
bombardments arc spam and many other
projectiles and for her passive all you
need is one ultimate accelerant and it
will give you 100% no matter what so you
can actually stockpile three or four and
basically have three or four Ultimates
ready at one point and any enemy that
passes through this fence will be hit
like an arc star and
be notified and like the Mirage decoy
icon for the entire team so you can tell
who is where on the map and be able to
kill them accordingly as for her
backstory Watson and her father actually
invented the ring also known as the
storm that collapses in gameis so
they've been here since the very
beginning of the apex games they were
the one that made the ring very exciting
stuff I'd love to see the rest of her
backstory which if it happens to be
released anytime today or anytime in the
future I will be sure to update you guys
on what that's going to be so definitely
be on the channel for that I love to
show you show you guys with the story of
what this character is what her actual
name is and kind of what she does
throughout the game and how she even got
her to begin with but lastly there was
this little tease and it says something
is happening in Kings Canyon as well
with this big ass I and I have no idea
what the [ __ ] this is this looks like a
big-ass dragon or some big-ass creature
as you can see there's these little
flying creatures this was pointed to
towards the leaks that there will be
flyable types of creatures that we can
use I believe they just called them
fliers that was there is a screenshot of
octane riding one of these guys in a
past couple months ago so this might be
true as for what this big-ass I think is
I have no [ __ ] idea but I would love
to see what this is and I'd love to know
your guys thoughts I think this is going
to be some either big monster that just
comes around and destroys half of the
map or happens to destroy a little part
of it or maybe just releases a bunch of
these Flyers and then we can use that as
well as the jump balloons that we can
use to traverse the map a lot easier
love to know your thoughts though in the
comments below and yeah with that that
was the 30 minute press conference from
apex let me know how much hype you guys
are having for season 2 I'm hyped I
cannot wait to hop into this game play
some Watson see this big-ass dragon all
this other stuff especially get the L
star for [ __ ] sake like that's gonna
be incredible yeah but let me know
everything about what you guys think or
what you guys I think that dragon thing
is in the comments below like the VP do
enjoy subscribe if you're new I covered
the informational side of me I like to
be if you do enjoy subscribe if you're
new I cover the informational side of
apex legends that being the balance
changes that your updates the patches
and leaks and stuff so if you want to be
kept up to date with everything
happening within the world of apex
legends and never miss out on an update
definitely stay subscribe to the channel
I was to cover the lore of Apex legend
so every characters backstory and how
they basically came to the apex games of
course like I've stated three times
already
this video about to be for that I'm
going to be covering Watson's Laura so
do not worry about that I'll have an
entire backstory video on her and how
she even got to this place in the first
place my two most recent pictures is
gonna be popping up on the screen if you
guys do want to check that out when that
guy's so bit of great stirred a bigger
parts in the video and peace out
take care
[Music]